if you could go back to when you were a
kid tell yourself one thing what would
it be that everything you think
that nobody else is thinking is actually
true
just trust yourself let me tell you what
i meant there i believed in a lot of
things under 20 that a lot of people
didn't believe in i believed that you
could be wildly successful if you didn't
go to college i ended up going because
my mom forced me in the end but like i
didn't really i believed that kindness
was like the superpower of being a
business supernova i believe that your
employees are your family not your help
or your enemy i believed everyone was
going to date on the internet in 95 and
that's what i want for all of you i
didn't believe this but what if one of
my friends believed that video games was
going to be a professional career when
it was popping off heavy in the 80s and
90s i would have not seen that i would
wish that that friend followed through
that conviction because they would be
the tony hawk of video games today if
they didn't my age ultimately what is
this message
you believe things today that most of
the world doesn't i think it's better to
stick to it and see it all the way
through especially when it's positive